- [Rachel] Hey, Joseph,
how excited are you
to answer 54 questions?
- Rachel, I'm super excited.
- [Rachel] Can you introduce yourself?
- Yeah, so my name is Joseph Ravichandran.
I'm a second-year PhD
student here at MIT-CSAIL,
studying computer science.
- [Rachel] And what are you working on?
- So I work on computer
architectural security,
which means that I hack
CPUs at the Silicon level.
- [Rachel] Now, when you tell people
you're a computer scientist,
what are their reactions?
- Honestly, most people want me to hack
their Facebook account.
- [Rachel] So you did expose
a security vulnerability
on Apple's M1 chip.
How did you do that?
- Yeah, so the way that
worked was we realized
that the Apple M1 supports this thing
called pointer authentication.
And so what we did is we thought,
if we were gonna make
this feature ourselves,
what mistakes might we make?
What flaws might we add to the system?
And we bought one of the M1s
and tested it for those flaws,
and we found that the mistake
that we envisioned was present.
- [Rachel] So how did you feel about
all of the coverage that this received?
- Yeah, so having the incredible
support of the community
really encouraged us to do future research
and made me just more
excited to keep working.
- [Rachel] So is Pacman
your favorite video game?
- It's definitely up there.
It's definitely one of the best.
- [Rachel] And what got
you interested in hacking?
- Yeah, so I grew up
making games in Unity,
and one day, I decided to
try to hack my own game.
Realized that it's very easy
to make insecure software,
and that kind of got me interested.
- [Rachel] And so what's
your favorite type
of challenge to hack?
- So I work on binary exploitation,
which means hacking programs
at the low-level assembly language.
- [Rachel] And how would
you describe ethical hacking
to a non-technical person?
- Yeah, so ethical hacking
means that I'm looking
for vulnerabilities in software
to disclose them responsibly
to the vendor, so that I get
there before the bad guy does.
- [Rachel] Who are some of
your favorite researchers
you've worked with?
- Yeah, one of my favorite
researchers to work with here
is my advisor, Menja Yen.
Oh, what's going on, Menja?
- How's the long summer.
Do students like it?
- Oh, it's been going
great. Everyone loves it.
- [Rachel] What's your favorite
hacking tool or software?
- It's a tool called
Ghidra that was released
by the NSA, and I use it
pretty much every day.
- [Rachel] Now, what's your
favorite MIT hacker prank
that's ever happened?
- Honestly, gotta be the cop car,
which is right up there actually.
And it's a classic, it's super cool.
- [Rachel] What's your process
for finding vulnerabilities in a system?
- Yeah, so there's really two
major approaches that I take.
The first is something called fuzzing,
where you kind of randomly
put inputs into a program
and just kind of see what breaks.
And the second is just
looking at the source code
and trying to figure out
what did the author miss,
what kinda mistakes might they have made?
- [Rachel] How do you balance
your hacking interests
with your academic responsibilities?
- Yeah, so luckily as a grad student,
most of my academic responsibilities
are hacking-related.
So I get all the hacking
I'd ever really want.
- [Rachel] What's the
most unexpected thing
you've learned from hacking?
- The most unexpected
thing I'd have to say
is just becoming very comfortable
as a beginner in new things.
So with hacking, a lot of the time,
you're a complete beginner,
starting with some new
technology you've never used.
And I found that the skill
actually transfers really well
to a lot of areas besides engineering.
- [Rachel] Common misconceptions?
- The biggest misconception
is that hacking
is an illegal act or criminal act.
Actually a lot of hacking
is done for ethical reasons
and actually helps keep you more secure,
like the hacking that we do here at MIT.
- [Rachel] So have you ever
taught anyone else to hack?
And how'd that go?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So if you wanna learn how to hack,
check out our course that we teach
that I helped design called
MIT Secure Hardware Design.
So go ahead and Google that
and you'll see the course.
- [Rachel] How would
you explain what you do
to a five-year-old?
- Hacking computers is
basically just tricking them
into doing something they
weren't supposed to do.
- [Rachel] Is there anything in this world
that's unhackable?
- So unfortunately I don't
think we're quite there yet
in terms of the defense technology.
We have plenty of innovation left to go.
In the meantime, it is kind
of fun taking the latest
defense innovations and
trying to break them.
- [Rachel] What's the coolest
thing you've ever hacked?
- Coolest thing I've ever hacked
has gotta be the Linux kernel.
- [Rachel] Any hacking
lingo you can teach us?
- Yeah, so I got two words for you.
The first is exploit, which
means to actually write a hack
for a system that makes it do something
it's not supposed to do.
The second is vuln, which
is short for vulnerability.
Vulnerabilities lead to exploits.
That's the part of the system
that's vulnerable to you hacking it.
- [Rachel] Are you always
interested in computer science?
- So I grew up learning
programming from YouTube
just watching YouTube videos,
and actually even started
my own YouTube channel to teach
programming to other people.
- [Rachel] So what was your
reaction when you received
the acceptance letter from MIT?
- Oh, I was super thrilled.
MIT's one of the best places
on earth to do research
and I'm super happy to be here.
- [Rachel] What was your first day like?
- It was pretty overwhelming.
I got to see the lab and meet my advisor
and meet all my new lab mates.
- [Rachel] And how would
you describe the community
here at CSAIL?
- Oh, it's absolutely world-class.
Like if you're interested
in some obscure technology
and you need an expert on that one thing,
there's definitely someone
here that knows that.
- [Rachel] Are you involved
in any clubs here at MIT?
- I actually just joined the
sport TaeKwonDo team here,
which has been a ton of fun.
There's really nothing
quite like getting kicked
in the stomach repeatedly
after a long day of research.
- [Rachel] Any prominent
figures in the field
who influenced you?
- I'm a big Steve Wozniak fan.
I was also really influenced by Zoz Brooks
and the greater DEFCON
community as a whole
as well as Palmer Luckey.
As a matter of fact, I was
actually one of the very first
Oculus Rift backers on Kickstarter.
- [Rachel] Hey, you recently gave a talk
at the DEFCON conference.
What was that like?
- Yeah, that was a dream come true.
Like I said, I grew up on
YouTube watching DEFCON talks
all the time, and getting
to be a part of it myself
was absolutely super rewarding.
- [Rachel] And during your talk,
you mentioned memory corruption tasks.
Can you briefly explain what those are?
- Yeah, so memory corruption
attacks are basically
just really confusing the computer
into doing something that it shouldn't.
- [Rachel] All right, is there an area
of computer science
research you'd really like
to work on but you haven't yet?
- Yeah, so one thing I've
never actually touched really
is programming language research
or writing new programming languages.
So it might be kind of cool to work
on how do you build a new
programming language for security.
- [Rachel] Are there some recent research
you're excited about?
- Yeah, so my group actually
just started pivoting more
into formal verification,
which I think is pretty cool.
- [Rachel] Can you tease
any future research?
- I would love to, but it's top secret.
- [Rachel] So if you're
stuck on a coding issue,
what are your ways to brainstorm
or figure out the problem?
- Yeah, so a big one for
me is hitting the gym,
lifting some weights.
Also going for a walk or
just a nice game of chess.
- [Rachel] Are you more productive
in the morning or at night?
- Gotta be honest, I'm a total night owl.
- [Rachel] What's one task
you wish was automated
but isn't that the moment?
- Ugh. Laundry.
- [Rachel] What do you think
about this crazy building?
- Oh, I absolutely love working here.
The fact that this place is so great
is precisely because it is so crazy.
All the crazy turns and twists
make you constantly lost,
and this means that
you're constantly bumping
into people that you
might not have otherwise.
And so this means that
a lot of conversations
and collaborations happen
that you probably wouldn't
get in a normal building.
- [Rachel] What's more annoying,
software bugs or hardware defects?
- Definitely hardware defects.
So the problem with the hardware defect
is that you can't run around
putting a new transistor
on every chip you've already shipped.
So that makes them way worse.
- [Rachel] And what's more annoying,
a room full of bugs or
software filled with them?
- Definitely a room full of bugs.
'Cause most software
already is full of bugs.
- [Rachel] Now let's do some
favorites, starting with chips.
- Apple M1.
- [Rachel] Favorite
computer science resource?
- YouTube.
- [Rachel] Favorite
computer architecture book.
- Hennessy and Patterson.
- [Rachel] Favorite class
you've taken so far?
- Nickolai Zeldovich's
security class here at MIT.
- [Rachel] Favorite place on campus?
- The gym.
- [Rachel] Favorite MIT traditions.
- MIT Henge, where the light from one end
of the infinite corridor lines up
and perfectly shines
through the entire hallway.
- [Rachel] Favorite music
that gets you in the zone
to do research?
- 90's Rock.
- [Rachel] Favorite concert?
- Actually, I just saw
Blink this past weekend
and they were really good.
- [Rachel] Best sci-fi movie.
- Interstellar.
- [Rachel] Best brand food
for a long day's work.
- Steak.
- [Rachel] Favorite restaurant.
- El Jefe's tacos are really good.
- [Rachel] Dream job after graduation?
- Literally anything that
just lets me hack stuff.
- [Rachel] Where do you
see computer architecture
and security headed in the next decade?
- I'm mostly excited to see
where we go with risk CPUs.
- [Rachel] Now, what's one piece of advice
from an MIT professor that's
really stuck with you?
- Yeah, I'd say the most
important piece of advice
that I've been given is from Menja,
which is to always apply
the scientific method
even in places where it
doesn't immediately make sense.
- [Rachel] And Joseph,
what advice do you have
to young students who are interested
in computer science and STEM?
- Yeah, honestly, just start hacking.
Go on YouTube, look up
some programming tutorials,
and just start creating something.
Doesn't have to be good. Just start.
- [Rachel] Thanks so much, Joseph.
- Thank you so much. Now
I gotta get back to work.
See ya.